hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Beowulf episode 2 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there are three big storylines
this week the a story was all about the
council voting the new leader to that
council of Thane's
the B story was Beowulf uncovering the
Skinshifter that killed ban in the C's
story was slain running into the band of
rogues with scorann who's played by
David Harewood who you probably
recognize from Supergirl I was really
surprised when I spotted him but I'm
guessing that they shot all of his stuff
before he started on Supergirl so a lot
of these episodes were probably shot
around the middle of last year maybe
like last spring or last summer but in
the context of Beowulf he is just one of
the things of the neighboring
communities he's just one of the other
big leaders in the Council of Danes you
can see that he had a good relationship
with Slains father probably knew slain
growing up so it's a really cool guest
appearance and a good way to add some
more complexity to Slains character
because after the first episode he seems
kind of like a dick now he seems a
little more human a little more
well-rounded like scran here has
memories of him doing good things
growing up so he's not all bad and the
same thing kind of happens as we meet
the other council leaders some of the
other people involved with the other
council votes start writing in all these
new storylines actually bleed into the
next episode the council vote the
Skinshifter and this little side trip
with slain and scran just explained who
all these new characters are so as part
of this a storyline this r8 character
who actually sees the mud-born from the
first episode just kind of teasing that
plot line along still a big mystery he's
Koreans younger brother the other people
there are warriors from their village
Beowulf goes to the part of town where
all the smelters work you get this
really Downton Abbey sense from it you
get a lot of like contempt from those
characters about people that work in and
around the Great Hall but this is Tam
the smelter he's one of the suspects are
going to question this is his mother
Kendra they actually meet her first for
most of the episode it seems like things
are pretty bad between those characters
in the characters up in and around the
Great Hall like Beowulf and the people
that he's been interacting with for the
most part but nothing brings people
together like an angry lynch mob which
is where the Skinshifter comes in it's
like a classic episode of The Simpsons
someone does something terrible in the
whole town just turns around the big
twist is that the Skinshifter is the guy
that was following Beowulf around the
whole time the new constable that's
replacing Bayon and it seems like he's
working for someone else so
Dickens but with the a storyline the big
twist is that rate doesn't want to have
anything to do with Rita he's like I'll
kill you we'll take your place on the
council will be voted in as leaders but
technically it's his older brothers
Quran who is the thing so he would be
the one that would become the leader so
just in the context of the narrative
think of rate as being like a slain type
character someone who starts out like an
antagonist but it's probably going to
end up being relatively friendly on the
other side of that equation I actually
forgot to talk about Abra kin in my
episode 1 video
he's Rita's brother he seems shifty as
hell you have to remember that he is a
Thane in his own right in the village
that Rita comes from and we have to
circle back around to that opening scene
Hrothgar's barrier because it opens up
the episode it's a really big deal
they're performing some of the final
burial rites and if you see these stones
around here this is just part of Norse
culture part of their burial rites this
is meant to be like a stone ship they
burn the body and then he begins to
enter the halls of the Dead that's just
part of their burial customs there's
still a couple really big mysteries
relative to his character but based on
the way he's presented the way other
characters talk about him it seems like
he was a pretty strong leader very
well-liked amongst the Council of things
like the other leaders in the area but
then then we have his secret son Beowulf
so we still have to find out about that
that's gonna be a big running plotline
across the entire season and they start
to tee up some of the mystery behind the
mud-born
some of the mysticism around the
mud-born in the Lost Tribe which is
another huge piece of prehistory of the
show that they casually slip in like
this whole tribe of people that was
brought to ruin because of what they
tried to do with the mud-born
so a giant WTF hopefully we'll make our
way back to that big Giants Hall it
feels like a lot of things go back to
there because that's supposed to be the
seat of power for the ancient giant
kings but I like the way they're teasing
out all these other groups of people
like where are you from how did you end
up here well I was I was part of this
other tribe of people even Alvey knows
past is relatively mysterious she comes
from a relatively mystic group of people
so I'm really excited to see what more
mythology the show is gonna weave out
really we're only in the second episode
so I'm expecting the next couple to
continue to lay some groundwork and
tease out some big storylines I know
everybody always wants to know what's
going on right away but usually like
when a new show comes on with a really
dense mythology like this they wrap
everything up with in the first season
most of the biggest questions but let me
know in the
comments do you think that the mud-born
are some remnant along with the skin
shifters of the culture that predated
man there's a whole culture there that
we don't know about like we have this
intelligent Skinshifter that's
protecting Alvina then we have the wolf
like once then we have the offshoot
which is a Skinshifter was just kind of
a different thing but let me know what
you guys think and just a reminder
episode 3 is gonna air this Saturday at
10 9 central on the Esquire network but
it's been a lot of fun so far it's
actually a nice break from the comic
book stuff that I do during the week and
if you have missed the first couple of
episodes they do have supplementary
material on their website it's Esquire
tv.com slash Beowulf so while you guys
wait for my next video to post just in
case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for my episode 1 video and
you can click here for my preview for
the whole series thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you